um hello that's so I'm going to talk
about Python for optimized
just to distinguish this is an
optimizing Python I think Mike spoke
about that yesterday so we're not making
Python programs go faster in general are
not optimizing websites or doing any
search engine optimization so hopefully
every doesn't understood that and we're
going to do mathematical optimization
with Syfy optimizers and Friends I don't
know how much you know about this so
kind of a show of hands of anybody's
used so I PI optimized before quite a
lot so you probably will know everything
I'm going to say and who's um used
linear programming before you quite a
few bit of background about me I'm a
quantitative developer so I'm you
talking about this stuff just as a user
I haven't developed any of these
packages so in my last three jobs I've
been optimizing credit derivatives
carbon footprints and currently bets on
football so you name it I've optimized
it so just for those who don't know the
it--what is optimization so we've got
some quantity F that we want to make as
big or as small as possible and why do
you want to do that probably because
somebody is paying you so f is something
that you care about google recently
announced I think they've made two
hundred million dollars extra by finding
the right shade of blue for the links on
their AdWords and this is quite possibly
a false positive but anyway suppose that
this is the amount of money you make
given the shade of blue so we have some
function f we have something X that we
can choose we're looking for the right X
perhaps also we've got some sorts of
constraints how we can't choose any X
we're restricted so then that case we
want to find the 200 million dollars in
the middle no shame clue also quite
possibly we're not dealing with just one
variable but I hope the multi variable
problem where we've got lots of things
to choose all at once applications but
this and this is very general we just
want something to be big or small so it
crops up just about everywhere where
there's data and anywhere where there's
data and you can say precisely what you
mean by good actually is the so this is
either because you want to take a
decision based on your data or because
you want to model your data to
understand it better and as soon as you
have a model you need to fit it and you
want to optimize some measure of
it the only time it's not going to be as
well as if you were doing something like
descriptive statistics or you trying to
find trade-offs you don't really know
what you want to do with it yet but soon
as you can be precise you can optimize
why is Python nice for this so I've used
Java and R and Python is the nicest
ecosystem I found for this stuff so far
for the reasons I'm sure you will
understand
it's the end-to-end nature of it so it
starts off with the really nice
high-level exploratory tools so the
ipython notebook and matplotlib and the
other nice blotting libraries this is
nice because optimization is inherently
so geometric so quite often if you get
the right picture you can get a nice
diagnostic and understand why your
optimization is working or failing
python is also nice as a high-level
modeling language to express our
problems a lot nicer than trying to make
sparse matrices stick together by hand
and pass it in to your C solver what I
particularly like is the fact that you
can often get a natural representation
that looks a lot like the mathematical
problem you were trying to solve in the
first place it looks a lot like your
equations from your likelihoods Python
also comes with batteries included so
we've got all the stuff inside pi
optimized and if we go a bit further the
stuff in stats models and even the
third-party solvers the commercial
solvers like Goro B and then C flex tend
to offer 5in bindings as well now and
finally an optimization can be
numerically and computationally
demanding so then it's nice when we have
syphon because we can use that to bind
other C libraries or to just get higher
performance cogenitor to use in the
inner loop so the rest of the talk I'm
going to just have a quick survey over
different kinds of optimization spectrum
from numerical to symbolic talk about
structure in our objective functions and
then we're going to look at a psycho
optimize which is actually a whole raft
of different solvers all stuck together
and look at briefly when you use one
rather than another look at Python as a
modeling language to build up problems
for an external solver like a linear
programming solver or convex over and
lastly we're going to look at sin PI and
how that can help you cheat with
derivatives
right so here's some data it's
completely random and here is an
optimizer I wrote myself in Python NP
Augmon so this does the job and it finds
me the value of x that makes f that's
more list but of course this is just
pure brute force method and it has to
evaluate F at all 1000 points so can we
do better with scifi optimized no of
course we've got because this date is
all independent so just knowing the
value of F at one point X doesn't tell
me anything about the value of the
function nearby so it's clear that we
want to get some clever speed-up so if
we want to optimize things efficiently
we can't just do this at any data any
more than we can compress random data we
actually need to exploit structure
that's in the problem already so here's
the other extreme this data has a lot of
structure it's completely linear but in
fact what we really need to know about
it for this purpose of optimizing is
that it's monotonically increasing so as
X goes up then F goes up so if I want to
make F small I just make X small and I
can find my optimum in the corner here
why is this important well if I want to
write an optimizer for this I don't
actually need to evaluate it at all all
I need to do is be told in advance that
the the data is increasing and lots of
problems have some sort of structure
like this for instance is some quadratic
data it's not as easy as the last one I
don't just have to go as far down way x
as possible but if I know something
about the structure of quadratic
functions I can tell that this one is
definitely going to have a minimum at X
is 400 and I don't have to go and
evaluate and numerically crunch through
this to do this I can if I want
numerically crunched through all this to
solve it that's perfectly fine way of
doing it if I'm not in a hurry and I
don't mind an approximate answer and I
don't want to think so the interesting
thing is that real problems are always
somewhere in between these extremes of
completely random and completely
structured if there's no structure we
can't optimize so we're always trying to
exploit what structure there is and
finds a nice way to express it and the
ideal case we'd be able to do everything
symbolically and we get exact on Stead's
instantly and of course you can't often
do that in practice perhaps you don't
know what you
objective function is perhaps it's given
to you in some black box or something
that you're measuring a noisy way from
the environment but this is basically
your job as a quant is to try and
understand what your problem is and then
do a sort of meta optimization between
different solvers and try and find the
one that's most appropriate so let's
have a look through what the general
purpose optimizers in scifi optimize do
for this sort of problem is how you call
them in general I've got a function is
my it's Expo of X minus 4 or squared
which is I can upside down Gaussian
function and I want to minimize that so
basic call is just I PI optimize
minimize as I'm sure many of you have
used already in this case the default
method has got us the answer of three
point nine nine nine nine nine nine in a
twenty four function evaluations which
is not bad so doesn't seem like there's
much to it and there's not much to say
in a talk like this but if you look
under the hood there's at least eleven
different methods that you could have
asked for in scifi optimize then the
question is what on earth of these lot
all four and what am I going to do with
them they will have different strengths
and weaknesses so the one we just used
them as BFGS which makes use of
derivatives it doesn't know anything
about the global shape of the problem it
can't handle constraints and so on so if
you want to pick through these you
really need to understand I'd be able to
characterize your problem so problems
can vary in size it could be a low
dimensional just a single variable
problem or having lots of dimensions
like this two dimensional one or
possibly millions of dimensions they can
be variously smooth so this is about how
they behave locally can I get as many
derivatives as I like at any point or
are there certain places where it
doesn't have a well-defined slope or is
it a complete disaster where no point
with his jumps all over the place and I
can't really tell much about the
neighbors from seeing each point and the
other really important thing is the
global shape of the problem so not just
about how it behaves locally but what's
the structure of the minima overall is
it linear where it doesn't really have a
minimum it just carries on going down
is there one well-defined minimum I have
a convex problem or have I got some
nightmare like this egg box function
which has got local minima all over the
place and if I just go down here and get
to some bottom but I won't know whether
it's the global optimum I'm looking for
or not so just to get a flavor of what
these different functions are doing
inside
Sify here's the Nelda mead optimizer so
where is it on the chart no derivatives
it's not trying to be globally optimal
doesn't handle constraints and if we
have a look at it and animation what
this thing is doing its evaluating my
function on three points it's called the
simpler simplex method so simplex in two
dimensions is just a triangle so it
valuate some three points and then it
decides given some heuristics should it
flip one point and reflect it through
the others or should it stretch the
triangle or shrink the triangle and
these rules are cunningly constructed so
that over time it converges to an
optimum which one it gets is obviously
going to depend where you initialize it
it doesn't know anything about the ones
over here but just the job nicely and it
makes quite few assumptions it doesn't
require me to try and differentiate
anything simulated annealing so I run
this on the same bump function and it's
taken 251 evaluations and it's not very
close to the answer has 2.6 and so it
seems on the surface like it's a bit
rubbish why would you ever use it but
it's trying to solve a much harder
problem which is trying to find the
global optimum out of the whole domain
it's based on a physical analogy where
glass is cooling down so we have this
temperature parameter so we start at
some point and we are allowed to jump to
nearby points and when the temperatures
hot we're really insensitive about the
shape of the function locally so we can
jump around a lot you can see in the
animation and the temperatures high it's
jumping around all over the place the
idea is that we'll hopefully find us
which of the basin's is the deepest and
likely to have the global optimum in it
and then over time we cool down and we
get less and less keen to jump out of
view the basin's and in this case it
manages to find some global maximum so
those two make quite a few assumptions
about the shape of the objective
function here's one Newton's method
which is really important this one is a
lot stricter about the assumptions it
makes so it's using the derivatives
every point so here in size I actually
had to think and work out the derivative
of this function f and pass that in it
doesn't work without it but once I've
given that in it's managed to get the
answer in seven iterations which is by
far the the quickest one we've had so
far it's doing something a bit like this
this is actually showing utans method
for route-finding rather than
minimization but the idea is if you know
the slope of your function at each point
you can pretend it's linear and work out
where it's going to cross zero and that
gives you a if your function smoothly
more behaved enough that's a really good
guess that helps you to converge really
quickly to the right answer for
minimization you're again you're
approximating the function by a
quadratic and trying to jump to where
the minimum of that would be so those
are just general-purpose solvers and
they'll do for small problems and
they're worth a try and not very
difficult to experiment with but if you
want to go really fast or you've got
really large-scale problems you're going
to need to use something more
specialized and a really important
special class of optimization problems
is linear programming so this is the
case where my up to my my objective
function is just linear and the
constraints in linear so you might think
that linear objective can't be very
complicated we've already seen that it's
really obvious immediately which way to
go to minimize this so linear
programming is really all about the
constraints and more than the objective
function so there's a nice package in
Python called pulp a quantum of what the
U stands for but it's Python for linear
programming this is nice so it gives us
for one thing it's abstracts away what
the solver is at the back end so it lets
us use different open source solvers
like
LPK or Kirino are to actually solve a
linear problem it can also use
commercial ones like goo Robi which do
tend to be a lot faster if you want to
shell out fritter if you've got an
academic license that you can use but
the nice thing is that you can just use
the same code to test on your open
source one and then move to the
something faster for production if you
want so it can still pulp just from pip
if you install that then you can now
play with Python objects that represent
things you're trying to optimize so
here's a little toy problem I'm trying
to minimize 3x minus y with X and Y in
some bounds here between minus 10 and 10
and of course that's very quick if I
look what Pope's actually done once I
brought the problem up these high level
objects its converted it into some
standard linear programming form that
it's going to pass as matrices to the to
the third-party solvers and of course
it's if you just make X as small as
possible and Y as big as possible solves
you this particular problem I can show
some pictures I made of what it's
actually doing so here's our objective
function is the shading obviously we
want to go in this direction to make it
small so linear programs have this
property that you're always going to be
at one of the corners your constraints
this is my minus ten in my plus ten
bands define some box and I just want to
be at the top-left corner of the box
which seems like a really
straightforward thing to solve and it is
in no dimensions like anybody can point
to the particular corner of a polygon
it's just not that hard if I add more
constraints then the optimum is going to
jump around in fact this is that you can
solve this in linear time in low
dimensions but it gets interesting in
high dimensions and because you might
know from SVM's and the kernel trick
things that are nonlinear in low
dimensions can be made linear sometimes
if you go to high dimensions just add
more variables more degrees of freedom
sometimes you can manage to encode quite
complicated functions by just this trick
of jumping up a dimension so sodoku he
doesn't seem like a linear problem at
all
but you actually can do it with this
same approach and
so he's only a slightly larger problem
it's still a toy really as well this is
one of the examples from the pulp
documentation I've got I'm going to make
729 variables this time so I've got one
for each value I could write in each box
and I've got for each box I'm going to
make a binary variable for each one of
those don't know if you can read all
that's disappearing off the earth isn't
it
so we make one of these that's a one if
there's a three in box and row two
column five and then it's quite easy to
encode the rules of Sudokus these linear
constraints saying that we have to have
exactly one value in each square we have
to have them one value present in each
row column and so on and the boxes and
then we can just put in the starting
numbers that would be printed in the
newspaper is these Lindt these equality
constraints setting those things to one
and also quite crucially here we've used
integer constraints so each of these
variables has to be between norton one
and it has to be an integer so they're
all binary indicators and chug-chug-chug
there's the answer to our Stokey very
nice and if you look here what you can
see so we actually express the problem
at quite a high level which Maps
naturally on to the way you think about
it as a human but once it expands out
you can see this is something you
probably don't want to be entering by
hand it's a bit of a nuisance and it's
nice that we've got some library that
connects abstract all this work away
from us and do it for us not all
problems a linear though so oops so
there's other similar packages that let
you use this slightly richer class of
modules so his CV X pi which is a for
convex optimization and again it's um
using Python as a layer on top to set up
the problems and define what you want to
solve and then sending it out to CVX ops
at the back to actually go and solve it
this is perfectly capable of doing our
linear problems as well I don't think it
could do the integer constraints but it
would be a bit slower but it does handle
this much wider class of problem
so here this is a lassi so you're
solving at least squares problem you say
minimize the sum of squares plus some
penalty on the sum of their coefficients
minimize the sum of the squares ax minus
B plus gamma times norm one you can
build up
CVX pie problems from this really wide
range of expressions all the normal
stuff arithmetic but also the log
determinant of a matrix or the smallest
eigen value or the KL divergence and the
nice thing about this is it gives you
all these parts that you can put
together a bit like Lego to build up
your objective but it also knows the
rules of which things you can combine
them how to make things convex or not so
rather than build the whole thing up try
and solve it and find out that it's
unsolvable because it's not convex it
can tell you all the way it can take an
expression and give you a clue as to
whether you've a hope of doing this or
whether you've misstep along the way
this is by leaving Vanderburgh who if
you come across the book Boyden
vandenberg convex optimization is really
nice resource and they also have a lot
of online courses at the moment and I
think you can get the book online for
free as well so that's one to look at if
you're interested what else so sin PI
and if you've come across the Fineman
algorithm for solving problems ever it's
quite straightforward you write down the
problem you think really hard and then
you write down the solution so this is a
kind of V the the way that we're trying
to solve optimizations rather than going
through and evaluating our function all
over the place we'd really like to be
able to do is just understand the
problem and know what the answer is so
if we want to minimize the sum of
squares so it's just a the most basic
optimization problem really the least
squares problem one thing we can do is
notice that it separable in each
variable so we don't need to consider
them all jointly and then we just need
to remember a tiny bit of a level math
so we can see we can if we can
differentiate this then we can know the
slope of the objective function at any
point here and also we can observe that
when the slope is
we must have reached the optimum we're
not going up or down so that's what
we're after so in this case we can do it
by remembering this very simple rule
that you bring the two down
job done but what if you want to
differentiate something that's a bit
trickier or something there's lots and
lots of terms or you can't remember how
to do it and you don't have access to
any sixth formers you could use a wide
variety of approaches you could use
numerical approximation so just evaluate
your function and subtract and take a
difference and there's a Python library
called num diff tools that will help you
to do this stuff Sify optimized will
also do a lot of it for you as well so
internally if you call some of those
methods so they need derivatives but you
don't supply them like BFGS it's
actually doing it just by taking these
finite differences that's one approach
it's can be a little bit inaccurate
sometimes and quite labor-intensive as
well lots of extra function evaluations
another approach is automatic
differentiation I don't really know of a
good way of doing this in Python
actually so some other library so Stan
from mc mc or the C++ stuff ABM B and
there's some stuff in Julia to do this
rather than have to either understand
your program symbolically or by just
taking numerical differences you
actually augment the numbers that you're
carrying through and augment your
arithmetic operations so that the
derivatives pop out at the end but I
don't know how to do that Python so the
other approach is pencil and paper or if
you're feeling really lazy you can use
sin pi which is great discovery for this
sort of thing so here's another example
and I've got some data it's normally
distributed I've got a thousand data
points from that and I want to infer my
mean and my standard deviation
parameters from that data so it is kind
of easy
so I expressed the likelihood of my log
likelihood of my data with a sin pi
function and this is what it looks like
so
this is the log-likelihood and that with
the mean varying at the bottom and the
standard deviation from bottom to top so
the optimum is going to be in there
which isn't surprising as that's the way
I generated the data if I do with soap I
minimize I'm just going to try and do it
with BFGS and kind of does okay it's it
seems a bit plaintive it's not totally
sure about its desired error this is a
point with Syfy optimized actually is
that you should always check these
warning messages that you get back quite
possibly
it's a success equals false here I think
it's actually managed to solve the
problem correctly but so here's the data
mean and standard deviation so this is
actually the mean oh it's a little bit
off of the standard deviation possibly
because this is a bit flat around the
optimum it hasn't necessarily managed to
pick it up so numerical optimization is
not always the best way to handle this
sort of thing simp I to the rescue so
how many people have used sin pi before
a good handful here so it's a bit like
Wolfram Alpha or Mathematica or
something like that
that you can type in expressions and get
it to do a your algebra for you I really
like using it in the ipython notebook
because it knows how to speak latex and
this knows math jack so it will just
looks really beautiful so when you're
stuck and you're puzzling away at least
you have the consolation of really
pretty mouse to look at so general
approach is copy the likelihood of
Wikipedia there it is for the Gaussian
distribution and it's done something a
bit odd with the route twos but
otherwise it has this nice property that
it looks the same as the thing you're
trying to as the paper you're reading or
the article you're looking at you can I
find it easier to read than this kind of
code so I have my likelihood I want to
take the log of it that's easy I just
take the log of it it just says log but
then I can actually get it to simplify
this and split it up for me as well
little bit of coaxing if I want to take
derivatives then that's now really easy
hooray
so I can just say differentiate
log-likelihood with respect to MU as my
expression didn't have to do any
thinking same things for Sigma so now
I've got this variable I can code this
up if I wanting to scifi optimize and
plug it into BFGS or I can carry on here
I can also get second derivatives which
is nice because quite often it's easy to
get the first derivatives and then you
suddenly realize once you've got lots of
parameters interacting that you're going
to have to do this for a whole great big
matrix and it gets a little bit
error-prone when you have a lot of terms
so it's nice to have something else to
do it for you you get very lazy so I've
got my first and second derivatives of
this problem here which are exactly what
I need to use Newton's method I can go
even further still and get it to give me
the actual answer and not have to
optimize it so it says given one data
point if you want to know maximum
likelihood mean it's just the value of X
like you didn't need to optimize define
that out same for the standard deviation
so that's very nice but thing that's
even nice there is if suppose we weren't
able to get our closed for all answers
here but we actually wanted to plug this
into a numerical optimization to help
speed things up is that it can help us
with that as well
so I can say Lambda Phi this so this is
my second derivative of the likelihood
with respect to Sigma I can ask sin pi
to wrap this up for me and it's going to
plug in number functions or math or H
and I get back a Python function here
that evaluates it for me numerically now
that really is something I can take and
plug straight into my optimizer and if I
time it and it's quite fast it takes 1.6
microseconds to do that but what if
that's not fast enough and I want to go
for a standstill so in PI actually knows
how to write C I'm going to be out of a
job soon at this rate I can ask it give
me the C code for this expression that
using the media might be differentiated
for me and in fact it won't just give me
the line it will give me all the header
files and projects and everything what
if I'm too lazy to even take that and go
and build my
Python Extension this is like even
better autorap go away autorap this
expression for me and compile it into
something in Fortran import into my
Python and give me back a function and
here we go and it's done it for me very
quickly and now it only takes 214
nanoseconds to evaluate so we're really
winning here I was playing with this
earlier I thought I'd dry it out for the
log PDF that we had in the first place
as I said just the log likelihood of a
Gaussian and it's able to do that and
just for comparison we'll just compare
that against the one in sci-fi stats
distributions yep
so a monster down to 12 decimal places
or whatever but look it's actually a lot
faster 197 nanoseconds to evaluate and
it takes Syfy stats attributions 86
microseconds so I don't know what
they're doing we can replace the whole
of sci-fi with it just simply running on
its own I think and that's basically all
the material I wanted to go over so to
take away if you're thinking about you
have some of these optimization problems
than you want to solve them and you've
got this amazing smorgasbord of solvers
to choose from if you've got a small
problem and you're in no hurry to get
the answer then just use whatever you
like and it will be fine brute force
anything that gives you an answer as
long as you check that the answer is
actually a maximum at the end that's
really nice there's not a lot of point
in spending hours and hours agonizing
over it you could go away calculate all
the derivatives plug it in and find that
it only slows things down because might
save you iterations but it's making you
take longer at each step if you've got a
big problem or you want to go at top
speed and every millisecond is important
then you really do need to understand
your problem and specialize as much as
possible so you should know whether it's
convex you should know if it's linear
even if you know that for instance
you've got a quadratic program to solve
it's worth checking the literature
because perhaps there's some specialized
super solver that's exactly right for
what you won
for instance in support vector machines
that's a quadratic program but there's
this particular sequential minimal
optimization algorithm that makes it
particularly fast because it's sparse in
a special way and that's often the case
Megiddo is algorithm for linear
programming if you've got a really big
problem you've got actual big data then
probably none of this stuff is going to
be too helpful because it's going to
take you hours and hours to calculate
every iteration but and you might want
to look into online methods like
stochastic gradient descent or Mira
descent and this is quite an active
research topic now if you don't
understand your problem at all and you
can always try a genetic algorithm we'll
probably give you something useful and
that's all I have to say I suppose you
have to look at the objective function
really and it depends if you have it in
some sort of symbolic form because it's
a model you're trying to fit there's
this thing called the convex calculus
which is what CV XY is talking about
which is you know if you take if you
compose convex functions and sums of
them and there's rules certain ways you
can combine things which keep things
convex so one thing you could try is
just type it into CV XY and go is this
convex or not if it's something like one
of my jobs before we were trying to
optimize ratings models we've just had a
black box externally we just gave it
some code it gave us back a number that
was what we were stuck with you haven't
got much to do there except for just
experiment and one thing that can help
is just plotting stuff a lot that
obviously only works really well in low
dimensions high dimensions it's not
going to work but if you perhaps you can
squash your data down in some way and
project it and just explore it really I
suppose
it is but doesn't mean you can't do it
yeah it can still take ages this tree in
fact is that you can if once you can
encode the constraints and any new way
you can solve it with a linear program
you solve that we just did then you can
actually solve it without the integer
constraints as well which is rather
interest and you can use an l1 up to
objective function and try to get this
fastest solution so it's allowed to say
or you can put point three over five in
there and point seven and over there but
because you encourage it towards varsity
it will actually tend to push everything
towards the ones and zeros so it works
surprisingly well as are so sometimes
you have a problem that could be
anything odd but you can relax it no no
quite absolutely No
quick question about these super solver
might be a silly question you said there
was a binary binary flag for each cell
so how big of a problem is one tonight
I'm guessing the binary value was the
binary value is there's a binary flag
for each number being in each cell so
it's not just one variable per cell but
one for each possibility you could put
in and you can strain them so exactly
one of the numbers in each cell is going
to be one in the rest of zero yeah I
guess I use them all for that really
anything that works I've had a lot of
questions you can ask about football
bets oh yeah I'm sorry Cooper or IO mo
its objective more than which basic very
basic Python and what it does is connect
your model you feel so good it's free
solar salad Gloria is constant for me no
I haven't used that one I think it's a
bit like pulp isn't it or one of these
other ones and those other okay yeah I
think this an open opt as well there's
quite lots of other packages I haven't
touched on it just these are the ones
I've got let some experience Adam
um good question I have not tested that
stuff out when there's certainly things
I've tried a ton it's right quite it's
quite likely to blow up and just not
come back when you asked it to
differentiate something complicated is
and I think there's things that
Mathematica or something could handle
that simple comment but generally it
would just neither work or not work I
think sometimes they see is not
particularly optimally there it will
have obvious redundancies in it or make
too many calls to X then you can tune it
further but certainly it's a good start
easy lending yourself
no differentiation and right right
unlikely to do it or whether other
languages are better suit I think we
don't have operator overloading in
Python I think that's one of the things
that makes it tricky it's easier to do
in C++ or a language like Julia we've
got macros but basically you need Plus
to do something slightly different or
you don't carry a lot of overhead from
chucking objects around I think that's
what's going on with Python okay no I
think there may be approaches I have
just haven't seen anything mature yeah